[Music]
[Music]
thank you thank you dean saloner
graduates family friends faculty dean
Joss
you know Honorable Condoleezza Rice I'm
sorry that RJ Miller could not be here
today he would be the one person in this
gathering that would refer to me as that
young man I graduated from this school
in 1962 more than half a century ago it
was a time when jet travel with just
beginning with the introduction of the
Boeing 707 there was no Silicon Valley
per se there were no fax machines there
was no internet there were no cell
phones no iPads the latest technology
technological development was the color
TV there was no such thing as venture
capital the number one company in the
world was General Motors the biggest
firm on Wall Street was Merrill Lynch
Pierce Fenner & Smith commercial banks
were not allowed to engage in investment
banking activities and there was no
birth control pill there was absolutely
nothing in my journey that has any
specific application for what awaits you
in so many ways today's talk could be
called return of the dinosaur why
therefore why before this the greatest
class ever to graduate from this best
business school on the planet
why why did the Dean asked me to be here
and my answer is I don't really know but
I suppose there may be some hope that
parts of my journey might be relevant in
attitude and philosophy I hope so but
why I a person who intensely dislikes
public speaking chose us to accept is
perfectly clear to me the answer is it
is personal for me it was a rounding of
the circle there's a part of me that was
born here I had come here at age 22 a
bit lost for me an extrovert was a
person who stared at other people's
shoes
shy insecure unsure what I wanted to do
with my life two years later I left much
better educated I was still shy and
insecure but I knew what I wanted to do
if only I could pull it off and that was
to bring to life the business plan
written in Frank Shallenberger
entrepreneurship class so I returned 52
years after my own graduation to this
place this magical place which is an
extended part of me a return to say
thank you here for all the aspiration
began in the summer between my first and
second year I'd had a long existential
debate with myself finally concluding
that I would before going to work for 40
years take one year to grow around the
world looking for education for
enlightenment looking for myself and in
the winter term of my second year I took
that entrepreneurship class whose roads
led to Japan so after putting in my
required two weeks of US Army summer
camp at Fort Ord selling my car saying
bon voyage to parents and fest sisters I
set out with Gary Carter well I met when
we were both living in brothers Hall in
September we were ready to go we drove
down El Camino to the liquor store that
was the ticket agent for standard
Airways a discount charter airline for
$80 we got on a convair 880 a prop of
course bleeding from Moffett Field eight
hours to Hawaii we would surf in the
mornings and sell encyclopedias
door-to-door in the early evening I am
sure I am the only graduate in the
history of this school whose first job
after graduation was selling
encyclopedias
after a month of this I was ready to go
on but Gary had met a girl he liked a
little too much to leave so now I'm
stuck with a decision go home or not go
at all I love Japan instantly the people
were friendly in many parts of the
countryside scenic and the end was 360
to the dollar so so many things were
affordable like hotel rooms and meals
and athletic shoes after a week I had
round my way to Kobe which was the
headquarters of an itsuka company
limited manufacturer of tiger athletic
shoes which I had identified as the best
quality the ones are the best chance of
getting a piece of the US market I
called in a telephone and explained I
was a US businessman in town and I had
an interest in distributing their shoes
in the United States I got an
appointment ID on my one business suit
Brooks Brothers with a blue oxford shirt
black necktie slipped on my black bailey
loafers and took a taxi so the wrong
location I couldn't read science I had
gone to the showroom they wanted me at
the manufacturing facility completely on
the other side of town so I show up a
half-hour late
I am already nervous and even though it
was a cool day I was sweating heavily I
met at the door by a 30-ish man Ken
Miyazaki who greets me warmly and
Usher's me through to a conference room
in the back of the building on the way
to the room would pass through the
accounting department which has about 20
employees they all stand up and bow the
big businessman from the US don't you
know
my entire assets are on my body that
business suit and my round-the-world
airline ticket it occurred to me that I
might not get out of there alive there
are half a dozen Japanese businessmen
waiting in the conference room how does
a shy and secure person make a sales
presentation sell as if your life
depended on it
which it sort of did didn't it but I
must contest when I said I sold
encyclopedias door-to-door in Honolulu
it was a little imprecise I called on
house in the door to door trying to sell
encyclopedias I never actually closed
the sale after a very awkward beginning
we got into specifics about what was
needed for the US market the talks warm
up and eventually become enthusiastic
they have been thinking about getting
into the US market and have several
track and field sample models built on
patterns of the u.s. foot they have an
all-purpose model and I called a limber
up they have a high jump model called a
spring up and shot just a shoe they call
the throw up I might be able to help
so we end with me placing an order of 15
pair of samples and after I leave I sit
alone and share in the chaotic Osaka
Airport and ask myself again where am I
going
I'm very excited about the meeting with
anichka and one part says this is
exactly what I want I should race home
and get this business going the other
said if you don't go around the world
now you'll not go for four or five
decades I flew to Hong Kong which is a
good thing the samples didn't arrive for
14 months when the samples finally came
in I showed them to my old coach Bill
Bowerman who was so impressed asked to
let him in on the deal we shook hands on
a 50-50 partnership and each of us put
up $500 we bought three hundred pair of
shoes first year sales were $8,000 we
made a $250 profit in 1964 my life got
busy by day I was a CPA for Price
Waterhouse my army reserve requirement
takes up two days to Tuesday nights a
month and one all day Sunday plus two
weeks in the summer dating with mixed
success and all the while my real love
is that little company that Bowerman and
I have started we get to $100,000 in
sales we get to 500,000 then a million
I'm multitask I can drive a car oedema
Connells fillet of fish sticks and
reading the newspaper all at the same
time I was pretty efficient for a couple
years until I rear-ended the car in
front of me
it took a lot of time to get insurance
companies lined up my own car repaired
and the cuts on my forehead fixed so I
don't do that anymore
by 1972 we got to two million dollars in
sales with a three percent net profit
but it hadn't been easy after all five
hundred dollars a piece doesn't provide
much equity even for two million dollars
I had tossed in most of my price
waterhouse checks for four years but I
was spending four days a week at the
bank trying to convince them to give us
a little more credit by now I've quit
Price Waterhouse and I'm going full-time
and somewhere in the process my search
for credit put me in touch with Mitchell
UI the sixth largest Japanese trading
company with annual sales of 100 billion
dollars we began developing a positive
relationship meanwhile and Itzik had
brought a 32 year old hotshot Shoji
Khatami
with a charge to expand export sales
export sales were primarily us so young
mr. Khatami brings me the following
offer tell us 51% of your company at
Book value or will set up other
distributors regardless of what that
piece of paper that we signed says with
Khatami's ultimatum I did an instant
cost-benefit analysis which led me to
this dilemma how do you say go to hell
in Japanese so there I am 34 years old
married a three-year-old son 80%
mortgage on my house forty five
employees the personal guarantee of the
$750,000 company loan inventory going
more obsolete by the day and no new
product to sell we had a team that had
taken that had been nothing eight years
before and built it up to become
recognized in the sporting-goods world
and that team had designed the three
top-selling Tiger running shoes we had a
large pot of coffee and the support of
the six largest Japanese trading company
and that trading Yemeni could and did
introduce us to every shoe factory in
Japan and provided the financing to
import those products but then there was
the little matter of the lawsuits plural
one in the u.s. one in Japan I get my
cousin Doug Hauser Stanford Law 1960 to
take our case on a contingent fee it
took three years we won both suits
meanwhile we paid $35 to a graphic arts
student at Portland State College to
give a rendition in the side logo in the
shoe the low row now called the swoosh
years later she was interviewed by the
Portland Oregonian asked her what her
second biggest project was she answered
wall wallpaper for a Walla Walla motel
read each of the 45 employees submit a
suggestion for a brand name Jeff Johnson
1963 Stanford graduate who I had met on
a workout at Angel Field and who was our
first employee submitted the name Nike
well I said I don't really like it that
much but it's better than any of the
other 44 and hope hopefully it'll grow
on us we were no longer limited to track
and field shoes so we bought brought in
wrestling shoes tennis shoes basketball
shoes as well sales grew to 3.2 million
dollars but our first we had our first
ever loss plus one other little problem
we got kicked out of our bank too much
leverage not enough cash
the state of Oregon only had two big
banks and we've been thrown out of the
other one two years before me shall we I
stood in for the bank until we found one
the First State Bank of Milwaukee Oregon
a small bank but we made it work so
there I was sitting at my desk more
relaxed than any time in more than a
decade in the period between getting cut
off by Tiger and establishing a banking
relationship with the first-stage bank
of Milwaukee Oregon sales mainly through
the introduction of a running shoe with
a waffle sole had risen to 25 million
dollars with solid profit really
profitability oh yes but at the top of
the morning mail letter has said United
States customers the announcement that
this is an important letter it turned
out to be so attached was an invoice for
pass through customs duties of 25
million dollars the exact same number as
our total sales for the year I had no
idea what they were talking about so
what we find out is there's a little
used part of the customs code dating
back to the 1930s duty in three
categories Benzedrine chemicals
cherrystone clams and athletic footwear
with synthetic uppers could be assessed
not the factory cost of the goods but on
the American wholesale selling price of
those goods if in
goods were like or similar if you like
that language to American manufactured
goods so here comes this invoice and in
spite of the fact that we've been
charged and paid the amounts that we had
been invoiced for it we'd been invoiced
for previously our prices had been based
on that and long ago been sold the
twenty five million dollars was on top
of that well but things were fuzzy and
in clear one thing fuzzy and unclear one
thing was absolutely certain no way we
were going to be able to pay that amount
of money so I go to Washington DC
reaching as high up in the political
ladder as I can
when first contemplating imported nylon
upper running shoes we had asked customs
for a ruling on what the duty would be
when shown the letter signed by the
Assistant Director of customs stating
our duty would be 20% of the factory
cost not to double that that we were
being assessed the response of John P
Simpson Deputy Assistant Secretary
well that letter is not binding on US
customs in other words we lied to you
you screwed up you trusted us and
gradually we began to figure it out this
obscure rule had been on the books for
nearly half a century and now us shoe
manufactures converse and others banded
together to lobby the government to
apply the extra duty on athletic shoe
imports in general and us in particular
they had to make something that met the
test of a customs officer who likely had
never worked in a shoe factory as in
like or similar and they then had to
sell only a few of those shoes to hugely
increase the cost of our shoes going
forward if in fact the retroactive part
didn't put us out of business which it
nearly did thus began the great ASP
fight a fight for our very lives it
lasted three years I am in the sneaker
business and I've got to have a
Washington DC lobbyist most lobbying
firms on K Street were more than willing
to take our case for a fee of $1,000 an
hour
we hired J Edwards Stanford 68 he had
just opened an office representing
Portland General Electric the Oregon
public utility and the nez perce a
Indians and now for a retainer of $300 a
month us ending over around and through
we fought like bastards our cause was
just the government was aligned with the
forces of evil and if we law
if we lost we're kaput but I believe
that fight made a huge imprint on our
culture which lasts to this day we
joined the American Footwear
manufacturers and then sued them we made
an inflammatory TV commercial which
ended with the tagline if this little
shoe company goes out of business a
little bit of Yankee freedom dies with
us no reputable TV network or channel
would show it we got on the air on a New
England religious channel between 12:00
and 1:00 in the morning it generated
three letters all of them positive that
having failed
we took a portable TV set showing the ad
during the presidential campaign of 1976
showing it in cafeterias diners and
pizza parlors all over New Hampshire and
that managed to get the attention of the
political establishment at least a
little bit and there was lots of shoe
leather in DC including plenty of my own
we had support from the Oregon
delegation plus Al Gore and Jim Sasso of
Tennessee where we had our central
warehouse and one of our meetings at
Treasury the official said you can tell
your senator Hatfield to quit calling
it's not doing you any good
I left his office and called mark Hyde
Phil's office and said keep up the good
work our 1 in-house lawyer rich Worstell
stanford 68 lived for two years in
washington DC he and Jay Edwards simply
out worked out thought out of motioned
the opposition and did a better job in
this case than any of those K Street
lawyers would have and perhaps our best
maneuver we came up with this one we had
a factory in Exeter New Hampshire making
15,000 per a month what if we created a
second line knocked off ourselves
selling the discounters are very low but
marginally profitable price no one could
copy us closer than we could copy
ourselves when this firms came up in a
brainstorming session everybody laughed
at its absurdity but then we looked at
each other the whole law was absurd
and it evolved into eventually
let's try it thus was born the 1:9 which
over a couple years sold a couple
thousand pairs and reduced the increase
in our duties by two thirds and after
three years of fighting we settled the
great ASP customs battle for nine
million dollars approximately one third
of the former demand and in those three
years our sales had grown to 140 million
dollars and we could actually pay the
bill
one year after the settlement we got a
SP eliminated from all from the entire
US Customs clove code for benzidine
chemicals and cherrystone clams as well
as footwear with synthetic uppers well
it would reach the critical mass to go
public all during the ASP years we could
not go public because we could not
actually report earnings which were very
materially affected by the ultimate ASP
resolution with the resolution of ASP a
public offering was open to us and in
December 1980 we did just that
and from that point the only thing
standing in the way of real success of
having our dreams come true was
ourselves I don't really like lessons
learned type lectures but there have
been a few along the way and on this
special occasion I can't help myself
indulge me I'll not be doing this again
now that you have graduated the goal
should not be to seek a job or even a
career but to seek a calling that search
has just begun your time here you've
probably gone through 50 or 100
different case studies and in the years
ahead you'll probably go through
thousands more those case studies are
not about decision making not even about
judgment they are about a search for
wisdom I have in my travels occasionally
met promising young people who insist
they are not going to ask for help along
the way they want to figure it out
themselves mine was the opposite
approach it is hard enough out there get
all the help you can
getting help really just a part of a
lifelong search for wisdom
here are just a few of the people who
stooped to help us along the way
and all but one of the following began
their help before we were ever a public
company Chuck Robinson Deputy Secretary
of State - Henry Kissinger Jill Conway
president of Smith College dick Donahue
at 28 years old the congressional
liaison for John Kennedy Ralph DiNunzio
president New York Stock Exchange
Tom Paine the executive director of NASA
Masaru hi-yaah me the president of Nisha
ey as we increased our volume we became
me show you is most profitable customer
in the world which got me into meetings
with their CBO
CEO we develop a friendship and for five
years in a row I spent a weekend with
him and his wife at their beach cabin
near Atami which wasn't just a pleasant
weekend it was also a tutorial on
business and leadership two years after
he stepped down from initial masa Roja
Yami was named the governor of the Bank
of Japan which is the Federal Reserve of
Japan when he passed away at his
memorial service in Tokyo for his
instructions draped over his coffin was
a Nike banner
and don't be afraid to come back to the
school that spawned you Frank
Shallenberger always raised my spirits
when when I was feeling low and want to
get a hold of it Bob Davis and Mike
Spence each spent 10 years on the Nike
Board of Directors and there are a
couple other lessons to Nine's working
together will be two tens working for
their own careers
every time ability and desire must
always trump money and power if you
can't get financing don't be afraid to
go 7,000 miles from home government is
part of business any business there is
such a thing as managing creativity and
dare to take chances
lest you leave your talent buried in the
ground and where there is no struggle
there can be no art and finally there is
this thought 10 years from now the first
of you will be asked to give the
commencement speech to what will lend me
the finest class in the school's history
you'll be a bit torn your multitask to
the max two kids one has an ear
infection and needs to get to the doctor
right away your husband is more needy
than usual and he has a flight in the
morning to Europe for 10 days your
company is at a critical point in the
strategic planning and everybody looks
to you for what the answers will be plus
the company has a PR crisis and you have
a TV appearances scheduled for five days
straight and that golden lab you had for
two years is all of a sudden decided
it's not housebroken there is no time
there is no time and then you'll accept
because of the honor because the chance
to have some influence on the most able
best prepared young people on the planet
and you will accept though it is hard to
see now because there is a part of you
that longs to go back to a place and a
time and a self forever gone and looking
for things to say include in your
consideration moments from the school's
history
you might even look back to that time
from the deep
past that moment over six decades before
when Frank Shallenberger beloved
professor of entrepreneurship said the
words that meant so much to me the words
that became a mantra for his class the
words that said the only time you must
not fail is the last time you try
[Applause]
[Music]